please be with you I'm idiot host
welcome to the D show exciting exciting
it's that time of the week you get to
put everything off and sit down and
enjoy the D show another exciting show
my next guest ten years he spent
investigating researching because at a
young age he started searching for the
truth yes and he saw the inconsistencies
the contradictions in the way of life
that he was living that he was brought
up in and it just didn't fit didn't make
sense and then he found this Dean and he
tried hard he didn't want to believe
that it was the truth he didn't but now
he's here on the Dean show today today
because he found out that it really is
and we really want to benefit from his
story and I'm sure you do too so don't
go anywhere we're going to be right back
with Brent here on the DS show don't go
anywhere
this is the this is the thing you know
this is the thing is Justine Justine you
this is the thing
welcome back to the G show peace be with
you
how are you saw Michael very well thank
you how are you good good thank God
how's everything Brett it's very good
very good
good to have you on Adi show it's a
pleasure to be here now I I opened up
the show and I just gave them a little
bit of a taste test I talked about you
ten years at a young age you know many
young men they're really not searching
for the truth but you were what really
inspired you at a young age to really
start this journey well I have been kind
of fascinated with like religion and
faith and existence and being for most
of my adult life and just from a very
young age like I just you know I would
read like the Bible read the you know
the Gospels or the parts of the New
Testament and it just didn't make sense
with what my grandparents or my parents
were telling me and it just there was
just so many questions I had and not
enough answers and so I spent like a
better part of 10 years or so just you
know researching like you know Buddhism
and you know I would you know read about
you know Confucianism or like different
parts of Christianity or Catholicism or
I finally stumbled upon Islam and it
just you know I have friends that were
Muslim the Persian and they just you
know would say oh well you know we can
certainly help you in this journey and
they would give me books to read and I
just kept reading and reading and
reading and reading and it just started
making more and more and more sense and
you know I guess it's just kind of
culminated in you know where I am
right now so I've been you know I guess
unofficially practicing for a few years
now just didn't take Shahada until
earlier this year so on
officially but officially you started -
you ended up taking the Shahada you
ended up accepting this way of life how
long ago into January beginning of
February very recently very recently yep
yeah so it's really new to you now still
but but you you have a lot ten year you
were studying Islam unofficially you
would write a Muslim we unofficially I
mean I like I fasted during I've been
fasting for Ramadan for the last
probably five years I you you know
dietary restrictions I've always held
those and I've you know I I just I
greatly admired the way of life and I
greatly admired like the discipline in
the and the you know the the love and
that I feel when I'm around other
Muslims so it's just you know that last
step that I didn't want to take or not
even didn't want to I just didn't feel
like I was like emotionally you're you
know mature or like it really
spiritually mature enough to like take
the next step and finally I just said
you know what I don't think that really
matters at this point it's kind of the
right thing to do so I just went ahead
and finally took the step did something
that a life-changing experience a
near-death experience because many
people are just caught up with life and
you know the guys just cruising down LA
with a dog on his lap listening to Tupac
bling-bling and he's just you know he's
not thinking about true searching for
the true money that's all it's under my
right right oh it's kind of really
surprising when you see someone that's
excited about really wanting to know the
purpose of life like you were seeking to
know what did something happened well
the culmination of a couple of things
that was in the military for ten years
well nearly ten years and just seeing
what I saw all deployed and doing you
know meeting different people and just
seeing like people under like you know
the most extreme hardships and like just
under you know the this this tyrannical
rule and and like just but without
running water and no food and like no
schools like no basic human necessities
but they still clung to their faith you
know like very very strongly clung to
their faith and you know I was it just
amazed me I was like that's incredible
like I've never met anyone like this and
it wasn't just like an isolated incident
it wasn't just like meeting one guy who
just happened to be very pious it was
like
categorically like almost ubiquitous
that every person I would meet was just
like well you know we don't have running
water and I can't so my kids to school
but you know thank God I have you know
like food to feed my family this evening
and or thank God I have like this small
thing or that small thing and it just it
made me wonder like you know that kind
of faith like that's something you know
I want to I want some of that you know I
want to get involved in that and that's
kind of what like really made me sit
down and like start questioning like
okay this is something that I really
want to like look into that I really
want to think about and then about two
years ago well not about a year and a
half ago I guess I lost my son
to SIDS sudden infant death syndrome and
the experience of just being in with him
in the hospital and kind of watching him
you know fade away it just it really
showed me how fragile life is and how
like very precious it is and it just
made me kind of take a step back and say
like I really need to get myself
straight so yeah how long ago was this
of October 14 2013 he passed recently
how old is he
two months old two months old him may
God Almighty allow reunite you with your
son inshallah and Jenna so tell us this
is amazing because you see a lot of
people complain about not having enough
jeans shoes in the closet right to have
the latest iPhone gadgets but you're
saying you're seeing people and the
other end of the spectrum of the world
and they don't have running water
right but they're saying thank God thank
God that you know I have like a pair of
sandals you know thank God that like I
have something to keep me out of the Sun
and there was one instance I the unit
that I was in was in charge of detainees
and some of which were like you know
probably very dangerous people but
others were persons of interest and I
ended up having to guard one set person
of interest and the only thing they were
allowed to have was a bottle of water a
Quran and
you know very basic food and just
watching you know the faith that he
maintained through that like and knowing
that like that's kind of how you know
under even those extreme conditions that
he could still maintain that level of
commitment and dedication it just it
made me really kind of step back and
question a lot of things we're going to
go back we're going to go back a little
bit then forward to get to where you are
today on this exciting treat of a story
it's Ramadan now officially you were
five but this is like your first are
real Rama doc so it's a treat brought to
you here by the Dean show don't go
anywhere with this exciting story we'll
be right back there are many
similarities between the historical
reference of Christianity and Islam
many people are amazed to find out that
according to Muslim belief Jesus is one
of the greatest messengers of God one
cannot be a Muslim without believing the
virgin birth and the many miracles of
Jesus Christ Jesus is also mentioned in
many verses of the Quran and is often
used as an example of good virtue in
character however the main difference
between Christianity and Islam is that
the Muslims do not believe that Jesus
was God please subscribe to the DCO
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on a Deen show with Brett and we're
talking about your story so people out
there they can know there's a lot of
misconceptions you know people right now
some people might be tuning in maybe
they're fat lot is Lama is the fast
according to the Guinness Book of World
Records it's the fastest growing way of
life in the world it makes sense and
people are coming to Islam because
they're investigating it they're seeing
that it makes sense and when you started
to investigate it did you see past a lot
of the false media hype propaganda and
yeah
did it make sense it does you just you
can't really believe what you hear in
the media it's just anything to make a
headline and I've never really been
invested in you know what's being
spoon-fed so I just I've always been
kind of the person to research it myself
and you know find out the truth for
myself and that's really what I did I
mean ever since you know
the unfortunate events that happen in
2001 you know Islam and fortunately has
been this boogeyman where you know
that's and it's portrayed that way in
the media and just I never really want
to take things at face value so I you
know I said well let me see what this is
all about let me see what you know is
really going on here like why are people
so afraid why why all this you know
concern and whatever so I you know just
obviously started to read like the Quran
and started to read just you know
different books different like histories
different just different things and I
just very quickly realized that you know
not only is the media wrong but they're
like completely off the target you know
they're completely off the mark and I
just thought that was you know very
fascinating seeing how completely wrong
everything was and you know slowly but
surely starting to like learn the truth
and learn how it really is and how like
how much that's how peaceful the
religion is and how wonderful the
community is and it just it was
life-changing yeah amazing tell us when
we go back you mentioned you were
brought up in a Protestant family yep
and you saw many of the inconsistencies
you had mentioned the contradictions
what do you mean by that well like
there's something about the Trinity
especially that always bothered me like
I just didn't I guess the biggest thing
is like the like thinking about God
thinking about Allah it's I think it's
lost on a lot of people like what is
meant when you say that it's the creator
of the cosmos this is the creator of the
universe and that's that's incredible
that's enormous and that's so much space
yeah that's a lot and I feel I just felt
like that was like kind of just
flippantly like thrown about like talked
about and without any like reverence or
respect and it's like why would the
creator of the cosmos have a son you
know it just didn't make sense to me or
like why would you know the creator of
the entire world the creator of the
universe like like he's not like there's
only one you know why would there why is
there like you know a father a son and a
Holy Spirit that you know there's
there's one God you know that's it to me
anyway and that's you know kind of what
I tried to find out is like why they
thought this way and why
felt this way and it just it just didn't
make sense to me and you know in Islam
it was you know made very clear that you
know there's there's one God there's
nothing equal to God
God has no son no equal and that just
just made sense to me that seemed very
logical so how about this part where the
belief that someone Jesus who we love
and revere is one of the greatest
messengers that was sent calling people
not to worship him obviously calling
people to worship the Creator God
Almighty but now people say look that he
died that he was crucified out of his
love God sent him to die for your sin
this is another basic belief what did
you think about this I just didn't
believe it
you know I just I mean it just it just
seemed very inconsistent with with the
rest of the belief system you know if
you're going to equate God with Jesus
and you think Jesus is God but he's also
the Holy Spirit and they're like God in
three persons and you know I'm not as
eloquent as most people and I can't
explain it as well as you know other
scholars may be able to but it just it
just didn't make sense like if you're
going to tell me God had a son why would
he let that son die you know and it just
didn't I just didn't feel like that was
something that an Almighty and
all-powerful God a court you know would
do and you know I just think about like
what islam teaches about Jesus and you
know how you know he was such a wise man
and a great prophet and like this you
know I mean the the way he taught though
there was the actions that he did the
things we can know about him like
historically and the things that we know
about him from like the Quran and the
injeel it's just like the complete
revolutionary fervor and like the
amazing person that he was I just feel
like it's like completely lost on
mainstream Christianity you know so you
really did your homework I mean 10 years
you're sick so you did go back to the
Protestant also Baptist and you looked
at the different denominations well I
was born as a Baptist and you know I you
know researched all manner and form of
the Protestant faith you know from you
know Baptists
I mean Unitarian assam you necessarily
Baptist but it's still a Protestant
faith you know and just different kinds
of
a different manner in form of
Protestantism or let that branch of you
know Christianity and it just you know
it just it just didn't make it to make
sense you know it's so many
inconsistencies and so many like
contradictions and you know just it just
didn't speak to me the way that Islam
did like Islam encourages you to ask
questions it encourages you to think and
be critical and and not only does it do
that but it also tells you like okay
well that's that's great let's if you
have a question let's talk about that
let's figure it out let's sit down and
think about why you think this and you
know we'll we'll figure it out and I
think that's beautiful I think that's
amazing that like not only is questions
encouraged but it's like you know that's
that's a great dialogue to have let's
let's figure it out let's make things
better for everyone you know instead of
like well it's this way because that's
the way it's always been and that's the
way it is yeah yeah many people don't
know we have actually more in common and
we never try to bash on Christian right
here anything but Salaam calls us to
reason let's have a dialogue a nice
conversation back and forth back and
forth and when people see like you know
many people don't know that we can go to
the Hellfire if we don't believe and
love Jesus right right but he never said
he was God right did you ever see that
in any version of the Bible that you
read that he clearly said I am God
worship me if you don't believe in me
you're going to the Hellfire no you
don't find you don't find it ya know but
when we ask Christian we say do you
believe he was gotten many many of them
because it's in their nature now to
reject a human being being his God when
you ask them do you believe he was God
or sent by God they'll say I believe he
was sent by God well that's what we
believe we believe was a messenger sent
by God calling you to worship God and
that's the me we're gonna be right back
with more of this incredible story here
in the D show don't go anywhere
so pull who allah say he allows one god
is one the maker america exactly a lot
of sunlit lost self-sufficient he
doesn't need food or drink he doesn't
need to rest on a seven
okay I really had a problem with that
even before I knew anything about Islam
God resting sounds like a weak guy yeah
lamb yeah lid when I'm you let he begets
not he doesn't have any children never
see a child or born of anything or
anyone well I'm yaqula lahu fly ahead
and there is nothing co-equal or
comparable to him at all nobody nothing
Jesus nobody nobody is comparable to the
Creator nothing yeah and that right
there was in his essence what I believe
naturally
please subscribe to the diva follow us
on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the Dean show a brett a ten year
journey now and finally decided what so
there was a point that you didn't want
to believe that islam was the truth yeah
i didn't want to believe it i guess
there was I mean there was you know I
was a rebellious young man like every
young man is and there was the time in
my life where I was like not an atheist
but I just I didn't I just didn't want
to believe in anything you know I just I
got so frustrated with like trying to
find you know commonality or you know
truth or you know just answers and
finally like there was some point like
May 22 23 I just said you know what I
don't believe it but like I just don't
think any of this is right and you know
there for you know a couple years that's
just kind of the way I went about it I
just got so overwhelmed and so
frustrated that like the atmosphere I
was in I didn't really have people to
talk to I didn't really have you know
friends or acquaintances or you know
family that knew about anything other
than you know like other Christianity or
you know whatever it was they believed
so I didn't have any kind of any kind of
reference point you know so I just got
really kind of down and kind of lost
track of what the purpose of all this
research was for in the first place I
guess but I quickly kind of grew out of
the head and decided you know it's
there's much more much much much more to
life than like this knee allistic kind
of you know there is no purpose sort of
thinking yeah more of a hedonistic just
fulfill your pleasure
right desires but at the end of the day
you're still a void right and was there
a void there with you oh absolutely it's
nothing felt fulfilling and I like no
matter what I would do I just there was
never that there was always that
emptiness that you that you felt like
just something in my life was missing
something and I couldn't
no I guess maybe I didn't want to admit
that it was God that I didn't want to
admit that like that's what my life was
missing and you know I would fill it
with all manner of things you know like
I would drink I would party I would go
out my friends I would you know just
stupid stuff you know materialistic
worldly things and at the end of the day
I'd wake up the next day and I would
just you know I'd feel terrible and like
I'd regret it or I just still feel like
that emptiness inside and not just not
being fulfilled and it just seemed like
no matter how much I would read or no
matter who I talked to I just didn't
feel like I was whole until I really
started to dig into Islam I call it the
lotto ticket syndrome people end up
scratching the lotto ticket because why
they think life then I'll finally have
purpose I'll make it and hit it I'll hit
it big and then I'll finally make it or
the people just experiment and they'll
just go ahead and win championships
Nobel Peace Prize or the person wants a
position at work or get this man get
this woman get this car get this iPhone
and finally I'll I'll be happy right but
it's like scratch a lotto ticket many
people when maybe they do hit it one out
of a million their life just gets more
flipped upside down or the person gets
to the next level right and they still
find out that you know what it's not it
this is now where it is now do you feel
it where you're where you need to be in
life tis that void filled well it is in
a lot of ways but you know it's it's
just it's an ongoing thing you know I
feel like it's you know like it's just
something I need to work on every day
you know it's not that like okay I
converted I you know pray every day and
I you know fast during Ramadan and I you
know hold the tenants so now I'm
fulfilled and now everything's fantastic
but you know I mean life is what it is
and yes things are hard and you know we
have troubles and you know difficulties
but you know Allah and my belief gives
me strength and gives me hope and it
leaves me fulfilled it leaves me feeling
like there there is hope that there is
fulfillment that there is you know
something there at the end of the day
when I come home and like it's been a
terrible day and I just filled the press
tour sad or lonely or whatever you know
just any number of things
you can just that feeling to know that
like that in the Islam is in my life
just recharges my batteries everyday you
know and helps me face every new day and
every new challenge that's what it is a
recharge with the prayer the salaat and
all the other things that we do out of
God Almighty's divine wisdom he
prescribed the things that we need to do
to recharge the heart and now we reach
this blessed month of Ramadan it's
really a recharge of our of our iman for
the whole year but that's the thing what
you just said it's like two people will
be on a ship and they'll go through the
sunder storms and the waves high but one
has the Creator with them one doesn't
right but they're still going through
the trials and tribulations but when you
have the Creator with you at the end
there's light at the end of the tunnel
right it just makes it much easier to to
face life I mean it's this is the
hardest thing you'll ever do this is
categorically the most difficult thing
any of us will ever do and if you
I think Islam you know I look at it like
like they're my tools you know it's you
what you wouldn't like I was in the
military you wouldn't go into battle
without a weapon and that's that's my
Dean you know it's going into each day
with arming myself with what I need to
you know face the world as it were
yeah and it's just like you know
anything you you now you have that
blueprint for life really and people can
relate to that it's a constant struggle
to be upon a path of nobility
righteousness do you see now how Islam
I've definitely experienced that I know
where I was before and I see how Islam
definitely is that medicine for the
heart helps to improve your character
relations with your family gives you the
reference point you go back to it when
you're making a mistake to write check
yourself
get in line do what's right do you see
that yeah without without a doubt I mean
so many times I just you know I get
caught up in you know the day-to-day and
like it's it's t it's easy to lose track
it's easy to let your mind wander or
like just get caught up in work and
your friends and relationships and it's
just I am categorically a better person
since you know coming to Islam and
deciding to live this way of life you
know I I'm healthier I'm happier I have
better more fulfilling relationships it
just it just makes me feel more complete
and you know when I do have a bad day or
when I do when something bad does happen
or you know I feel sad or lonely I mean
it just it's it's there you know it's
there's always you know that you know
return point and like especially the you
know praying it's it's so meditative and
so like just peaceful and I just feel
like it's it's just very respectful and
very just calming and it helps just like
Center me and like bring me back to
what's really important in my life you
know my you know God and my faith and
that's that's ultimately the only thing
that really matters and yes helps bring
me back to that you know it's ironic I
mean you know you have a lot of people
with strange ideas in the media it's not
helping this and then you also have some
Muslims we have take accountability who
don't have the proper education Islam
they do things and now obviously doesn't
represent Islam but the media just loves
focusing on them they loved you know
it's imagine the media focusing on a
fringe element like the KKK and all the
people got to see but that's what they
do now with these groups like Isis and
whoever else is out there and constantly
just bombarding American people so for
the people who's just watched Fox News
and they see you and I say oh man this
guy now he's one of them I'm an American
I love my country you're in America you
served your country I served my country
with you know with honor and I you know
to those kind of to those people that
say that or to think that it's you know
I mean the proof is where it is I mean
like I love my country I love living
here I just happen to be Muslim you know
it's I'm a soul I was a soldier I served
you know two different tours in Iraq
honorably with some of the best men and
women that I've ever met and I just I
you know you see these portrayals of you
know Islam in the media or not even I
don't even think it's Islam you know you
see like Isis and al Qaeda and you know
those kinds of people and that becomes
like a reference point for people or of
like the representation of the whole
faith but of course that's not it of
course not I mean you know we you don't
look at the KKK and say oh all
Christians are like bigots and you know
small-minded of course not so why would
you do that to this long you know but
it's it's just it's easy for the media
to make it out to be like this boogeyman
you know yes and you know it's my I feel
like it's like my responsibility you
know especially being you know veteran
especially being like new to the faith
you know to to be a positive you know
force to be you know a positive
representation of that to say like you
know Islam is a you know it's a peaceful
religion it's a beautiful religion it's
you know it's a wonderful religion and
to be part of that and to you know bring
it together with like every other aspect
of my life just I think it just shows
that like you know each of these
different things aren't mutually
exclusive you know you can't it's not
like you if you're a veteran you can't
be a Muslim if you're Muslim you can't
be a veteran or you can't be American
and a Muslim it's it's it's part of the
way of life I mean that's the beauty of
America you know yeah well I really were
at a time I really have enjoyed talking
with you
I benefited tremendously from your story
I'm sure the viewers have also thank you
very much and we started with peace we
talked about loving Jesus is a mighty
messenger we talked about and the peace
that he brought calling people on it was
Islam peacefully submitting to the one
who created you and now you're a Muslim
was doing that action and will also end
with that greeting that Jesus greeted
his followers with peace be with you and
also with you
salaam like so and though you had
another very wonderful story with brett
somebody drives the Toyota or Honda you
don't call him a traitor now because he
drive in a good car he switched over
from maybe a Chevy that's his choice so
this person decided to do what Jesus did
put his head on the ground praying to
God Almighty alone Jesus never as he
found out ever called we love Jesus go
to the Hellfire we don't believe
you know but he never called anyone to
worship himself as a god nor did he ever
say - he was a literal son of God what
does that mean
cats have kittens dogs have puppies
cows have calves what does God have baby
God come on man you know that just
doesn't make sense and there's no proof
for it but Jesus was a mighty messenger
who called people to submit themselves
to the Creator to heavens and earth he
was a Muslim that's right and our
brother here found this way of life that
just makes common sense worshiping the
crater not the creation doing good being
good to your neighbor being the best
that you can be but you go through
struggles and it reminds me of a
beautiful hadith where the last and
final messenger Mohammed has said that
no affliction befalls a believer except
that is good for him even the prick of a
thorn you get rewarded for your patient
and is good for you so when good comes
to you say thank God I hamdulillah and
when a calamity strikes your patient
hamdulillah and at the end there's the
reward of Jenna so there's light at the
end of the tunnel and there was someone
and they'll conclude with this that said
that I dare someone to find anything
better than driving through a lay with
their dog on their lap listening to
Tupac well this person hasn't figured
out life nor the purpose of life and
this brother has because when you do
that's when your heart becomes alive
it's charged up and you finally have
that peace and but contentment that
money can't buy and you then you don't
need to be scratching those lotto
tickets or having a lotto ticket
syndrome you finally got it you finally
want I hope you enjoyed this week's show
have a blessed Ramadan subscribe if you
haven't already to the d show call us if
you have any questions criticisms you
want to chat 1-866 to islam we'll see
you next time until then peace be with
you please subscribe to the DCO follow
us on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below